bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france quelles sont ses
chances d'être acquitté alors à quitter
je ne sais pas parce que là pour le
moment ce qui est en jeu c'est de savoir
s'il va être extradé aux états unis et
ses chances de ne pas l'être sont
juridiquement forte parce que il
m'apparaît que c'est évident qu'il est
sous le coup d'un procès politique d'une
part et que il a subi et va subir des
traitements inhumains et dégradants s'il
est extradé aux états unis
d'autre part maintenant on a une série
depuis quelques mois maintenant de
signaux très négatif sur la capacité de
la justice britannique a organisé un
procès équitable
comme l'a dit son père et vous l'avez
entendu il ya quelques secondes
personne n'a pu le voir jusque depuis le
mois de février
ses avocats n'ont pas pu préparer sa
défense ils n'ont pas pu le voir
physiquement et il ya quelques semaines
seulement quelques jours seulement plus
tôt un nouvel acte d'accusation a émergé
ce qui rend en réalité la défense de
julian assange très hypothétique dans ce
type de dossier et qui fait craindre le
pire c'est à dire un retour vers les
états unis qui comme l'expliquent ses
proches seraient probablement une forme
de d'arrêt de mort et dans le cas où la
justice britannique décide de ne pas
l'extrader cas seront les suites
judiciaires
alors si la justice britannique décidé
de ne pas l'extrader il serait
probablement normal qu'on regarde la
persécution politique dont il est
victime
il sollicite l'asile
dans le pays qui sera celui qui
l'accueillera et dans lequel il faudra
vivre qu'il s'agit de la france de la
suisse de l'allemagne ou de l'angleterre
même mais il est vrai qu'on est obligé
de prendre dans ce dossier les choses
étape par étape et qu' il faut que le
monde entier comprennent que s'il était
extradé aux états unis
c'est probablement la fin en fait de sa
capacité à se défendre de ce dont on
l'accuse justement sur ce dernier point
dans le cas malheureusement d'une
extradition aux états unis
les conséquences de cette décision pour
julian assange risque techniquement 175
ans de prison donc pour un francophone
175 ans de prison ça n'existe pas on n'a
pas ce type de peine dans notre arsenal
législatif faut savoir que si une
personne coupable de ce dont julian
assange se défend en france seraient
condamnés à même pas deux ou trois ans
de prison
et encore ça serait totalement délirant
pourquoi parce que qu'est ce qu'on lui
reproche au fond c'est d'avoir diffusé
des informations vraies qui démontre que
les états unis ne respectent pas la loi
donc on n'a pas d'équivalent possible on
n'a pas de possibilité de comprendre
comment fonctionne ce système et
notamment ce qu'on redoute aujourd'hui
c'est pas les 175 ans de prison c'est la
torture dont il est victime des mots
mêmes de l'expert des nations unies de
par la surveillance la détention à
l'isolément les pressions sur ses
proches qui font craindre que en réalité
un procès impartial aux états unis est
totalement hypothétique vous faisiez
allusion à un acharnement judiciaire
est-ce que ce point précisément dans
quelle mesure est ce que en france on le
prend suffisamment compte pour pouvoir
accorder un éventuel
un éventuel asile politique à julian
assange alors la difficulté d'un asile
politique ce qui suppose que la personne
soit sur le sol français on imagine mal
que la france va envoyer des
hélicoptères pour permettre à assange de
revenir en france
ce qu'on attend en réalité peut-être
c'est une déclaration qui est symbolique
voire même une prise d'actions
politiques de la france pour dire que
nous n'avons pas cette vision là de la
justice nous ne pensons pas que la
sanction peut être imposée sur quelqu'un
avant même soit jugé nous ne pensons pas
que le fait d'informer librement doit
donner lieu à une peine de prison
et nous ne pensons pas et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui qu'une personne qui est
objectivement non dangereuses identifié
doit être d'assez isolement 23 heures
sur 24 et il doit être traité comme le
pire des criminels alors qu'aujourd'hui
il est avant tout un journaliste un
éditeur de presse et dans tous les cas
il mérite de pouvoir se défendre
efficacement
alors justement quand on parler
d'acharnement judiciaire dix ans de
rebondissements pour qu'on comprenne
bien finalement ce feuilleton en ce qui
concerne donc le fondateur de wikileaks
des conditions de détention difficiles
que ses proches dénoncent sur ce point
précisément que pouvez vous nous dire
écoutez moi je les rencontre au début de
l'année 2020 j'ai vu un homme qui était
extrêmement fragilisée qui n'a pas vu la
lumière du jour depuis plus de dix ans
ça paraît fou
qui était effectivement détenu dans une
prison de haute sécurité dans un
quartier al isolement avec des moyens
d'information de réaction extrêmement
réduit je veux dire on a visité des
dizaines de prisons dans le monde entier
mais les la situation de son
incarcération là est particulièrement
inhumaine et choquantes comme l'a dit un
de vos auditeurs
ce qui est étonnant c'est l'indifférence
générale dans lequel cette torture
institutionnels se déroule est donc un
des enjeux de la défense d'assange c'est
de rappeler qu'aujourd'hui il est
poursuivi pour de la prétendue diffusion
d'informations et qu'à ce titre ils
devraient être protégés et non pas
persécutés merci à vous antoine et v je
rappelle que vous êtes l'avocat français
de julian assange